hi shelby
hi steve how's it going
fine thank you and how about you doing
great
all right so we are going to
do
a series of videos about french
and learning french on link which i
think will be useful for people who are
learning french and in particular for
people who are using link and especially
if they're using link to learn french
so
uh now just to get some background you
speak which languages
english and spanish
okay and you in fact lived in a
spanish-speaking country for a while
right yes i lived in ecuador and then
chile for a total of about a year and a
half oh okay so you would say that your
spanish is
very fluent yeah advanced
advanced
so so that means that you have some
advantages in learning french
sure i think even english speakers have
an advantage learning french when i
think of myself learning arabic or
persian there is no common vocabulary
someone who speaks english has already
got
half the words in french just that
they're pronounced somewhat differently
and they might have slightly different
meaning but a lot of the words are
recognizable
and of course with your spanish that's
even more the case
right
yes i mean it is okay so you've got an
advantage so you're gonna i suspect you
can in three months
uh you can become quite good at french
and so we're gonna see if that is in
fact the case now
as i always say in language learning
there are three key ingredients first of
all the attitude of the learner second
of all the amount of time the learner is
is willing to spend with the language
and the third thing is this more
nebulous idea of of this ability to
notice to some extent we notice
subconsciously as we you know spend more
time with the language and if we're keen
we notice more but there's always things
that we don't notice and
in this series we're going to go over
some things that i'm going to point out
to you that maybe you noticed maybe you
didn't notice
and my hope is that it'll help you
notice many many more things because
ultimately we have to notice what's
happening in the language so that we can
gradually develop new language uh habits
so first question is what is your
motivation to learn french
well i uh kind of learned spanish on
accident because i had to in high school
and i fell in love with the process and
i loved that learning spanish opened up
all of these doors and windows of
opportunity that i never could have
imagined um but it also really broadened
my perspective and helped me see the
world through
other people's lenses so
once i started learning spanish i
realized that i would want to acquire
more languages to be able to continue to
grow that broader perspective
okay so it's kind of a general interest
in learning languages you've chosen
french yes uh there is an expression in
french which i
i'm sure you'll understand la petite
so the appetite comes with the eating
so i have often had the experience that
as i start into a language the more i
get into it the keener i become and i
think you'll find that with french the
more you get into it the more
interesting things there are
the more enthusiasm you'll have for the
language
uh then the second question is time um
now my language learning day consists of
about 45 minutes to an hour of listening
which is listening while making
breakfast listening while cleaning up
listening while working out listening
while in the car
and all of that adds up to 45 minutes or
an hour and then i'll put in another
half hour of deliberate learning on my
ipad typically using link how much time
do you think you have available
daily to spend
with your french learning
yeah i i have the same common excuse
that everyone has which is i don't have
enough time but i decided a couple years
ago i need to not have the time and and
just make the time so
um i would like to be able to commit
actually what you said 45 minutes to an
hour uh maybe some days an hour and a
half depending on what i have going on
right because i know that i've been
watching your videos so i know that
consistency is key
right
are you
like me able to listen to languages
while doing other things
yes
okay some people say they can't do that
yeah i like you too i i can't sit down
and focus on just listening i can read
and listen but i can't just listen
because my mind will go to other things
that that's a very interesting that's
the paradox
it's almost as if if there's other
things around you that you for example
if i'm sitting on a plane
that's tremendous study time because i'm
stuck there i have to do it uh
whereas if i am sitting at home there's
always the temptation to go and do
something else yeah if i'm already doing
something else like making you know
cleaning up or whatever
cleaning the garage so then i'm doing
something else so then i can listen but
to just sit down and listen i get you
know uh
ants in my pants after five minutes i
gotta get up and do something else so
not everyone finds this but some people
you know
give it a chance try to develop the
ability to listen even if you're not
focused all the time maybe you're
focused for 60 of the time but all the
time that you are focused in on the
language while doing other simple tasks
that's all very good exposure and in a
way it's free time it's dead time time
that otherwise you wouldn't be studying
so
i think this ability to listen while
doing other tasks
using the convenience of mp3 technology
of our iphones or our smartphones or you
know mp3 players it's a it's a
tremendous tool people should try to
develop the ability to do that
absolutely
okay now uh the sort of dedicated
learning time for me is on link
and so uh
let's perhaps share your screen okay and
uh see uh
what that might mean and we'll try to
i'm gonna try in each one of these
lessons like today i want to focus on
some general ideas about pronunciation
and just leave it at that you're still
going to have to get used to the
pronunciation yourself but i'm going to
try to do some things that might help
you know this
maybe in the next video we'll look at
some other issue might be word or
word order or tenses or something so
every uh one of these we're going to
focus in on a specific aspect of french
where i'm going to point out a few
things but i can't point out everything
because most of these things you're
going to discover yourself
okay okay sounds great
we're in the library and so you see what
other people have been studying
uh-huh
and just to point out a few things that
might be helpful for people who aren't
familiar with link
in the 15th number 15 of the mini
stories there's only 27 unknown words
so what that tells me right away is that
you have in fact you have been
into the first four i think many stories
on your own and i like learners who
don't wait for the teacher like there
are some language teachers or teachers
of anything tell the class you mustn't
get ahead of you know where the class is
you know that the teacher controls what
you're going to learn and the good
learners in fact they just go ahead
because they're curious so you have done
the first four mini stories as a result
a lot of the vocabulary that shows up in
the 15th mini story you already know so
there's only 24 27 new words here
on the other hand the
the one below that studying by being
studied by someone else has like 45
percent
so you know
you're gonna find that like a sweet spot
where you want uh you know just so many
new words but let's go to can we go to
my lessons you're my lessons area
so
and i see you have
again that's very good you have gone
ahead you've opened up
uh
some lessons
we see that le channel you have like two
percent new words i guess you've done
that
uh whereas the
beginner two one has 59 new words so
that's kind of a little tougher but
let's go into the many stories because i
i'm a great believer in the many stories
i think they're a great place to get
started not the only place to be
not the only place to be because
because you want to be alternating i
think it's very important always to have
some basic stuff with lots of repetition
but also to explore so let's open
since you've done the first four on your
own which is good
uh let's go into lesson number five okay
[Music]
now
uh
so
uh what we can see right away
is um
there are blue words
and there are yellow words and there are
white words so just i'm just gonna
digress a bit here before we get into
french not everybody's familiar with
link so the yellow words are words that
you have
encountered before
words that you didn't know you looked
them up but they're still yellow because
you still don't feel you know them
anything that's in white those are words
that you now know they were yellow at
one point and they became white
uh the blue words are words that you
don't know
one thing that i would do it's not a big
deal but
you've got an a there
now of course a is also a word in french
if if anything that's like
not really a word i tend to remove it i
call it you know ignore but in this case
a is a word in french so we leave it
so
uh
the blue words let's first go through
the blue words on that page now i tend
to go through reading to myself and just
eliminate all the blue words convert
them all to yellow
so the first word
so what do you do with that i i'm
curious what do you do with a name
well uh it's interesting because i
i was just linking it
because i wanted the blue to go away
um but i was just watching one of your
videos this morning and what you
actually said that you
do just what you just said that you
ignore them so
because it doesn't count it's a proper
noun right that's right now it turns out
that unfortunately in the current design
at link it's hard to find the ignore
button
it's a lot easier when you're on the app
uh in the new design which is
in a month or two
it'll be easier to do that so i tend to
use the keyboard
and i just hit x
okay
like the the mac virtual keyboard
yeah i have a keyboard here uh so i just
hit oh i can just i can do this on my
keyboard yeah x just hit x there oh cool
so x is to ignore
and if it's a known word you can hit k
for no
oh cool
so i find that easier yeah so i i when
i'm on the like most of my time i'm on
the ipad but if i'm on the computer i'll
use the keystrokes like the arrow keys
to move from
word to word link to link
uh have you used the arrow keys to
progress in the lesson no i have to hit
your right arrow
okay
oh did you see that you moved from 11 to
lisa right mm-hmm yeah
so uh all right at least say
uh
you see the meaning there
yes
so
right
so now
yeah so one of the things you can do
what did you do did you hit enter
oh i just clicked on it okay you clicked
on it so you can save it there's many
different ways you can save it you can
click enter you can save and you can in
your settings and i won't go there right
now but you can set it up so that it
automatically saves once you move past
it i think that is in fact the default
so if you move past that once you've
been on a word if you've moved past it
it's going to save
right yeah now it's yellow
okay
so you've moved on to ah do you know the
word ah from avoir
um
goes
no oh two or two or four
it that can be although that's incorrect
because now that's one of the problems
with a dictionary
that uh let's
let's look at popular translations you
see where it says popular translations
okay so actually
you can see that it the one we want here
is
has
there we go and in fact i guess you know
i'm discovering things about link that i
didn't realize
ah with an accent means at
uh ah without an accent is has it comes
from the verb
okay
which in spanish is
tna
correct
so
that's something to notice
okay
and then you can go with your arrow to
the next word
okay
okay and that's homework it also means
duty
okay
and let's go to the next
blue word and then i'm going to talk a
little bit about pronunciation
okay
right
okay so you can take that
okay
so you'll notice that there's a lot of
repetition in this message this uh
page in this lesson but uh you're gonna
go through and find all the words you
don't know and you're gonna listen to it
many times and gradually get used to all
of the words and phrases in this lesson
i just want to focus on some aspects of
pronunciation that you want to notice
you want to be aware of when you're
reading because when we read
in a language we tend to self-vocalize
so even in an early stage don't worry
about how well you can pronounce it but
you want to be aware of how it's
pronounced so that when you're
sub-vocalizing you're
at least a little bit you know feeding
your brain something that approximates
french pronunciation and what is
sub-vocalizing some vocalizing means
that when you're reading even even if
you're not reading out loud
i find maybe you don't find this but if
i read in english it's meaning i don't
say the words to myself
it's just meaning
because that's my native language when i
read a foreign language i have a
tendency maybe not even entrenched for
me but in a language that i'm learning i
tend to
say these words to myself in my mind
so there is an element of pronunciation
going on yeah i'm not saying them out
loud but i'm saying them to myself
because i'm not yet familiar with them
and so in that sense
if you're going to self-vocalize and i
think most people do then you have a
have to have a sense of how they're
pronounced
that's why for example
i like listening before i read
so i will listen i might listen to this
you know a few times before i attempt to
read it i listen to it i don't
understand it but i'm hearing it i'm
hearing it i get some momentum and then
with that momentum then i go and try and
read it so then i have a bit of a sense
you know it just gives me a bit of a
start on on reading it so try and
pronounce just the first three words
of this sentence or of the first
sentence
okay
julian
perfect
what you did really well was one of the
key things of course in french is that
not all the vowels are pronounced okay
it's not s if that were spanish that's s
but it's not spanish it's french so
all by itself the word is e
e julia is but what you know caught up
on is that when the
consonant is followed by a vowel
that consonant all of a sudden comes
alive
and it connects to the following
consonant so judy the other thing we
notice which is again important in
french pronunciation spelling
a lev okay so we got three different
ways of saying e there we got a which
the act where the accent is
towards the right
elev which is a long e where it's
sloping to the left and then we got uh
at the end that's sort of neutral
and there are some
mostly disappears okay say the next
three words
here again you've done very well because
the don all by itself is don with that
french nasal sound but because that
consonant is followed by a vowel the z
drags on to the next one
okay let's take the next sentence let's
try that whole sentence as one big
mouthful all right
okay
is a very common word mucho okay
shows up all the time
never ever pronounce the p
okay
so uh you just have to get
even even if it's followed by a vowel
like it's just always boku boku boku
boku boku menu boku ilabokudo
okay as a spanish speaker you have to
correct the fundamental flaw that all
spanish speakers have
it's
it's not de
it's the okay italian voila italian
speakers do the same thing so say it
again that whole sentence
uh one thing again that i i stress with
people is
when you're listening notice again that
in french it's relatively monotonous
there are singing languages like swedish
and english where we are up and down the
french are not so up and down they're
kind of monotonous the more you can
capture that
the better your pronunciation is going
to be and it doesn't happen overnight
but at least if you notice it while
you're listening to the language you'll
notice how it tends to be somewhat more
monotonous and if you can notice it you
have a better chance of developing that
happen
okay next sentence
university
so
of course you have a strong spanish r
there but that's okay people get over
that
uh
now
one of the things that's important it
has to do with pronunciation but also
with one of the things that we will talk
about in another
lesson is the question of gender
so
in this particular case it's a female
student so it's not just grammatical
gender she's actually a girl
but you'll notice that the word etudion
would be a male student an etudiant
and sometimes you need to emphasize that
don't be don't be reluctant to pronounce
the uh at the end of a word that's
actually quite sophisticated and french
so
claire etiquette
all right
so say the whole thing again
university
well very good okay
uh
so again just to sort of summarize we're
we want to be focusing in on while we're
listening on the sort of monotonous
nature of french we want to be aware of
the liaison
uh like even um let's see
so we have this liaison that's going to
come up time and time again try to
notice it when you're listening
and and if you notice it because a lot
of people find french difficult to
understand because of liaison they say i
can't tell where one word ends and the
next word begins because in fact the end
of one word is dragged into the next
word so you've got to start noticing
that and then you'll have a better
chance of being able to you know
identify the words
and um
and the other thing is that the the e
sound can either be a
or o
right
so you again those are things to to
notice and and i find that if you if you
sort of make the effort to notice
certain things you'll also start to
notice a bunch of other things
and you may become curious like it seems
to me that this is happening is this
happening and then as you listen more
and more you'll see that that is in fact
what happens
um so let's read the last sentence there
this one yeah okay
okay
le devoir perfect except it was a bit of
a devoir we wanted
but still that was very very good okay
let's go to the next page
you know and it's um a little bit
challenging for me to accomplish the
monotonous tone because i speak
so non-monotonously
so um i'm gonna practice that but if you
have any tips for me on doing that or if
it just comes down to noticing more and
more the only tip i would uh give you is
don't worry about it
you're not going to change overnight
uh
the brain is very good at picking up on
patterns
but it does so slowly
and so you will be you'll continue to
speak the french with a little bit of an
english
or even spanish i don't know sort of
intonation
your brain might say hey this is a
foreign language so therefore your
spanish
control center might kick in
uh but in time as you listen more and
more you'll find that you're able to
sort of morph into a french speaking
thing it's not going to happen overnight
so i just tell you that so that you're
aware of it but you won't change
overnight
my experience in language instruction is
that people continue to they move very
slowly from whatever established pattern
they have into a different pattern so
that's that's not not a big issue okay
so now we have some blue words let's
first
remove those blue words
all right
so i guess i could use the arrow key
to play is that correct yeah i'll try to
do the keys here play
all right next
computer
that's a cognate with spanish okay
leah
reed
also a cognate with spanish mm-hmm
it clear that's not a copy it is oh it
is it's yes
to write
and then let me just
yeah i'll just point something out very
often when you have an e with an accent
sloping to the right
or the circumflex accent
it indicates that there's an s there in
other latin languages
really yeah so that's fine a call is
school a call school a call
okay
so very often if you're struggling
to figure out what the meaning is if you
see this e accent aegis is called in
french there's an s missing
oh that's really good to know yeah so
yeah because yeah in spanish
yes yeah
and eton do i just thought of that 800
is extended so sometimes it's an x okay
cool
uh in fact uh for you as a spanish
speaker there's lots
of cognates there m
jouer
mm-hmm
but it's also duty yeah duty
is easier
they're better
right
so
you will find lots of cognates let's go
to the last the last blue word there
oops
yeah sir sister
yeah so now
uh
again you're not gonna do it overnight
but the french sound er
er say sir
so
perfect okay that's a key word comes up
all the time
so uh
i just we won't go through the whole
lesson uh one thing one last thing we
might do is
we didn't do it for the first page but i
i don't think we will do it i'll leave
it to you but obviously if you go to
the
arrow in the middle of page right hand
side of the page
that's going to take you to the next
page
but below that is another arrow
and that takes you to your what we call
like review activities
so we won't do that now but you can go
through all of these words
and go through them in flashcards and
there's closed tests and dictation and
different things
and i find that
at an early stage
in a language i like doing them
every time i turn the page
because i've just encountered these
words in the text and to review them one
more time sort of isolated in these
activities kind of helps me
and and very often like particularly
here where there's so many cognates and
so you didn't recognize at first that a
fear was just
but now you do so in fact you say i'm
moving it to normal because i know this
work amy i'm
if you feel comfortable you can move it
to known and
one other bit of advice because we're
talking about french but we're also
talking about using link don't be
reluctant to move words to know
some people say well how do i know i
really know it and i can't use it yet
and stuff it doesn't matter i think
known is can you recognize it in a
context
because you want to be exposing yourself
to more and more content you'll be
seeing that word again and again which
is maybe a reason if you're not totally
confident you can leave it as yellow so
you'll see it again highlighted in
yellow in another context but after a
while if you're comfortable
you know recognizing the word when you
see it that's good enough you'll always
have a much larger passive vocabulary
than active vocabulary that's even true
in our own languages we recognize many
many words when we read that we know we
seldom use but in particular in a
foreign language you know you want to
get to consuming more and more content
seeing words in different contexts
because when you speak to someone
typically the native speaker has a much
bigger vocabulary than you do
you need to understand what they're
saying so that the passive you know that
comprehension sort of
um
vocabulary is extremely important not to
be you know scoffed at and if you find
that you've now forgotten a word you can
just go back and save it again i can
i could
lower this down to right and and i do
that all the time i find myself moving
it in yeah show us where you did that
again yeah
you can see this over here as a known
word and as you see it it's not yellow
anymore
but then i could move it downward um
towards a lower ranking and then it
changes back to yellow
i i find that uh so one of the things
that you're doing well and maybe we're
going to end on that note this is less
than five so there's 60 mini stories uh
the first 20 are all in the present
tense
they're after it's a mixture of tenses
and we'll therefore we'll get into these
other tenses later on but i tend to do
them in groups of five
so i don't stay on the first one until i
can totally understand it when i listen
to it because that's just not realistic
your brain
needs to get used to language so no
matter how many times you listen to
lesson one there's always going to be
parts that you don't understand so you
want to move to lesson two lesson three
lesson four lesson five then go back
again to lesson one so you treat these
five lessons as a group and try to
listen to them often
and so all of a sudden the elem jouer
elem jouer it's not like in spanish
one of the things you could do
is say phrases because in english we say
he likes to play but in french he says
and so you can you can mine this these
five lessons not only for the words you
need
but
for phrases like another one you could
save so you've got to save that now
you'd enjoy okay there we go help from
link and another thing is joey
not there he likes to play on his
computer
so that's kind of useful you know that's
a phrase and and you can save jouer
okay you can take the whole sentence
but uh
the thing is if you take just jouer
you're coming up with a phrase that
might repeat might repeat
okay
uh because there will be situations
where we jouer avec play with so so you
can mine all of this material for
phrases which you save for a while and
then you unsave them you don't need them
anymore
but if you save them then when you do
your review activities you'll be
reviewing those phrases which can be
very helpful too
and so you mine this material you listen
to it over and over again
but the objective is not to fully
understand the first five lessons the
objective is to get yourself a lot of
exposure because there's those five
lessons then you move on to the next
five
so let's just leave it at that and uh
that's our lesson one
uh shelby learns french
i'll be learning in public with your
help there we go and we'll be covering a
lot of different things explaining some
of the functions of link
uh pointing out some things about french
but uh
your main job is to identify to find
things on your own and if you're curious
to look them up you know if you're
curious about something to do with the
grammar um you can look it up on google
i happen to believe like everyone likes
to have a book get the smallest this
happens to be italian but get the
smallest little grammar book you can
find with without exercises which you
don't need with some sort of a summary
explanation with some examples the
smallest one you can find with a good
index and if you're curious about
something you look it up
not again with the objective of nailing
it down but just to get that additional
exposure to you know some of the
structures of the language at any rate
and steve i just regarding the
functionality too i just wanted to point
out that what what people can't hear is
because i have my headphones on is that
i'm also listening to these words and
phrases as i'm clicking on them so i'm
hearing that pronunciation exactly the
text of speech uh
you know you can't listen to a whole
lesson in text-to-speech because it's
too annoying it's
you know scientific voice however for
individual words and phrases it's very
useful
very useful what you should also point
out maybe you should click on sentence
view
i don't even i've never done that all
right so if you're
there we go okay we should show this now
click on the audio icon there okay
all right
did you hear the natural voice yes i did
okay so
with the mini stories
we have time stamped them so
if you're at a beginning stage you may
want to go through them sentence by
sentence okay
and then you can review those saved
words in your review activities it'll
only be those that are in that sentence
click on translate sentence
oh
so if you're in sentence view you can
get a translation of the sentence you
can hear in a natural voice that
sentence spoken
and then you can review
just those words in your activity and
you could save some phrases there and
just review those in your activities
um
awesome
yeah and i i always i stay in sentences
you until i'm comfortable i can do it in
sentence view then i go back and do the
whole thing in page view
all right one thing to point out that in
the app the uh
switching from sentence view to
is a little different than this but the
principle is the function is there
and and again it's also a very good
place to practice pronunciation because
you talked about or we talked about the
sort of more monotonous nature of french
and and in any language you want to try
to capture the intonation of the
language
uh it's a great way to make sure your
your phrasing is right and your your
individual you know word pronunciation
is good
uh so if you listen to that short
sentence and then trying to repeat it
don't don't bother recording yourself
but don't do it now but i'm saying it's
a good place to practice because you're
dealing with a sort of a finite you know
a limited amount of
of content
right and i know a lot of people want
their pronunciations to be corrected by
a teacher but i've also seen in your
videos that you you'll do that you'll
listen to the natural pronunciation from
a native speaker and then you can even
record yourself saying it and compare
you can do that
i would not recommend it at an early
stage sure because you're you're only
going to
reinforce
your ability to pronounce french will be
much better in two months than it is now
so just do it without recording yourself
just assume you're getting it right
okay and and just let let the and do
more spend more time listening to it
listening and listening and listening
and and slowly you'll get better at it
and just for fun maybe once a month uh
record yourself we don't have that
function built into link but it's easy
enough to go and report you record
yourself somewhere and compare yourself
it's fun to do as a record so here i was
on june the 4th and look at me now and
it's july the 4th
but at any rate yeah so we've covered a
few functions thank you for pointing
that out
and uh we will continue
yeah i'm looking forward to it thank you
okay
good luck
bye-bye steve see you later
[Music]
you